- [Voiceover] - Lighting's on point.
- [Voiceover] - Ooh my balls!
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- I mean how many movie posters
have you seen with LGBT people in them?
- Brokeback Mountain.
- Oh yeah, that's a good one.
- We're not as represented as we should be
for being as big a percentage
of the population as we are.
- Like there was a token and you're like,
oh shit there's just one?
Why is there only just one always?
- And if you don't identify
with that one token,
it's like who can you identify with?
- Trans people are people too,
and, you know, we're here.
We've been around.
- I know for a fact that having
actual bisexual people out in media
would have made my coming out experience
way easier because I fell prey
to the mindset that you had to be
one or the other for the longest time.
(upbeat music)
- Your eyelash is tickling my lip.
(laughter)
- [Photographer] Shoulders down.
(upbeat music)
- I'm ready.
- I'm excited!
- Let's have like all of you.
This is a movie about Demi Moore.
- Ghost is actually one of
my mom's favourite movies.
- I'll be recreating the
Magic Mike movie poster.
- [Voiceover] I shouldn't
see much of your eyes.
- [Voiceover] I'm so excited,
it's one of my favourite films.
- Trans guys can bring it too,
and I just want to show the world.
- We're about to pose for
'The Fault in Our Stars',
a movie I have personally never seen.
- It also touches base
for high school audiences,
because even today in the media the few
LGBTQ represented films, it's
typically an older generation.
- You're like, eating my eyelashes.
- Your eyelash is tickling my lip.
(giggling)
- I'm excited for this photoshoot.
- I can't wait to be DR.
- I can't wait to be - oh is my fly down?
I can't wait to be Cher.
(laughter)
- I'm really excited
about, taking this, like,
iconic gay movie and putting a twist on it
where the gay characters
aren't just the best friends
in the background, but
we're like front and center.
- And you know what,
we shouldn't be hidden!
Shit, we're people too.
- I'm super pumped.
- I am so happy. Can I be Superman?
- [Voiceover] I warn you,
I brought Kryptonite, so...
- [Voiceover] You are my Kryptonite.
- I don't know if that's
a compliment or not.
- I think that went great.
- [Voiceover] I was feeling myself.
- It was tickling my nose,
the chest hairs, a little bit.
- I have chest hair?
- Yeah, you do.
- Well.
(laughter)
- I thought it was cool.
I was a little bit nervous
at first, you know,
we all have scars and stuff that we're
becoming more comfortable with
but I had a ball overall,
and I loved doing Magic Mike.
I think that it's important
to show trans youth
and LGBT youth that the
options are just endless.
The sky's the limit.
- I just think it's important
for LGBT media to exist.
- I feel like movies
and film are, you know,
it's an escape for people,
and it's hope for people,
so I feel like we should be
represented in that hope.
- Fuck yeah there should be more
LGBTQ people in movies! Shit.
- I think also seeing different types
of gay men in the
forefront is important too.
- [Voiceover] Not all gay
men fit into the, like,
role that is carved out in the media
and don't look like that and
I feel like a lot of times
if you don't look like
that, it can be a struggle.
- It's badass. I felt so
badass, looking at it,
I was like, wow.
- [Voiceover] The kids that
are growing up these days,
they should see more
of their people, like,
that that is gonna help them
like, become more themselves
and like, be, you know, whole.
- You can do anything and be
anything that you want to.
(upbeat music)